amor e respeito às verdadeiras
necessidades em todas as etapas do
desenvolvimento constroem um indivíduo
capaz de tomar suas próprias decisões
vivenciando os ambientes preparados
podemos ter experiências que nos
permitem despertar memórias e viver
nossa criatividade intensamente sem que
tenhamos que seguir padrões que não são
biológicos um ser humano autônomo
conhece e convivem em paz consigo
estendendo seu respeito e amor a tudo e
todos estes são os parâmetros que
norteiam a educação ativa um processo
dinâmico observador e íntegro sobre
educação
esta vertente se base em conceitos
propostos por jean piaget humberto
maturana no antecessor iene pico entre
outros pensadores ressalta que na
natureza jamais existem relações
instrutivas possibilitar o aprendizado
não é ensinar é viver o momento presente
em conexão e aprendendo com as crianças
esse é o projeto casinha amarela é um
espaço de ensino e aprendizagem que
valoriza a necessidade dos indivíduos e
ficar em campo largo no paraná
nós chamamos de pedagogia viva eu sou
talita sua mãe educadora terapeuta
mistura de yoga
mas posso dizer pra vocês que depois que
o espaço da casa amarela começou a
funcionar
esses títulos e informações já não
escreveu mais quem é essa pessoa eu vou
contar para vocês porque claro que em 18
minutos é quase impossível falar de
coisas que mudaram uma vida ou muitas
vidas mas eu vou tentar
depois que o nosso primeiro filho nasceu
um parto em casa
delicioso nascer do sol canto do galo
quando a gente pegou aquela criança nós
recebemos sentimos uma grande
responsabilidade
naquela época as pessoas ficavam dizendo
nós mesmo mundo deles como é que nós
vamos trazer as crianças e o que me veio
foi que filho que eu quero deixar esse
mundo
então nós começamos a buscar informações
e referências cursos estudar muito sobre
educação a gente conviveu em algumas
comunidades em alguns grupos que se dá à
educação
em algumas comunidades a gente não se
identificou muito porque o treinamento
com a criança era muito forte em outras
deixavam as crianças para terceiros
educar enquanto justificavam desapego e
pra gente desapego consiste em estar com
as crianças acolhendo diferentes
então a gente fez um último curso que
abriu muitas portas
a gente começou a entender a educação de
uma forma amorosa respeitosa e aí
juntando esse curso com um pouco de
informação que a gente tinha
fomos pegando um pouquinho de
e quando eu fiz steiner um pouquinho de
mpe clima antecessores o de meneghetti
maturana e fomos trazendo para o dia a
dia e nós decidimos então participar
ativamente da educação dos filhos
naquele momento a gente sente uma
insegurança a pressão familiar a pressão
social
as pessoas diziam mas sem um
direcionamento sem sala de aula sem
professores como é que seus filhos vão
aprender alguma coisa como é que vão
aprender a ler
como é que ele vai ser socializar e eu
não tinha a mínima idéia de como
responder isso mas eu sabia que tinha
que pegar esse caminho a gente nesse
momento de decisão a gente já estava
grávida do segundo filho e a
sincronicidade exibiu abril as fotos a
gente descobriu um sítio ou mudamos pra
esse sítio tinha tudo que a gente
precisava
tinha uma parte uma área para o plantio
de agrofloresta tinha uma casa para a
gente mudar e mais uma casinha amarela
casinha amarela vê como algo
transformador
era uma casinha inteira no tamanho das
crianças tinha tudo que elas precisavam
sem perigo ativo ea gente ficava ali
observando as necessidades delas e
criando um ambiente para que essas
necessidades fossem satisfeitas
então isso fazia da casinha um espaço
dinâmico e sempre em transformação
constante transformação e uma
metodologia bem simples
a gente criou os ambientes do que
representou no dia a dia da criança
cozinha o escritório da mãe
o banheiro o mercado música todos os
espaços que representa um dia a dia mas
cenária jardinagem
a gente criou ambientes craque para as
crianças trabalharem os sensoriais então
tato olfato paladar e outros ambientes
para conexão com a natureza
então a os a natureza por perto a digi
laraya água os animais estavam todos
acessíveis para as crianças estarão
interagindo a gente também
trouxe jogos motrizes do trabalho
equilíbrio lateralidade e os jogos de
educação para trabalhar matemática
português biologia enfim o que as
crianças precisassem todos os jogos bem
organizados nos seus lugares bem
acessíveis para que as crianças pudessem
usar e guardar no mesmo lugar
e nesses jogos representativos várias
coisas acontecem teve um momento em que
chegou essa criancinha a hora que vi um
banheiro do tamanho dela uma privada
dinha e um limpador ela ficou em 40
minutos limpando aquele banheiro
concentrado a gente conseguia tirar foto
ea mãe como eu ficava o lado ali porque
ela estava ansiosa para que a criança
terminasse aquela atividade fosse fazer
outras tantas mil coisas que tinham para
fazer na casinha mas a gente acolheu a
mãe e conversamos sobre a necessidade da
criança de estar representando que a mãe
também faz né
e aí é calmo
então todas essas atividades que as
crianças vivem então relacionadas com a
necessidade interna delas isso que as
mães sentem esse sentimento de ansiedade
pra criança termine ou o sentimento de
que a criança faça alguma coisa mesmo
que a mãe não demonstre as crianças
manifestam
então a gente passou a estudar
ressonância e aí como essa situação por
exemplo a você vai cair né ea criança
acaba que em tudo que os pais sentem a
gente acaba criando então se eu estou
inseguro eu posso chegar mais perto do
meu filho italy incentivar com que ele
faça uma coisa que ele tem necessidade
e essa ressonância a gente tem até um
caso interessante porque chegou uma moça
uma vez com uma filha
foi a primeira vez e aí a criança chegou
e começou a mexer em tudo e começou a
brincar no jogo e foi trazendo todas as
outras crianças da loja chamou nem você
brincar comigo você foi controlando você
vai fazer isso você vai fazer aquilo que
você vai fazer aquilo que é um erro foi
observando falou nossa
a minha filha está controlando todo
mundo ela não precisa fazer isso ela
pode deixar com que cada um faz ótimo
idade e aí a gente pegou aquela mãe
sentamos na fogueira que elas sentem
fogueira conversa né
então a gente senta na fogueira e aí a
gente perguntou por ela você se
identifica com esse sentimento de
controle ea mãe disse sim naquela hora
ela falou eu sou controladora eu não
preciso fazer isso posso deixar que cada
um crie do seu jeito
e olha que ela falou aquilo ela contou o
agente que foi como uma febre que foi
subindo pelo corpo dela inteiro e ficou
tão bem resolvido pra ela que hora que
ela voltou pra assistir a menina
brincando
ela conta que deu um tiro na minha vida
parou olhou o que eu estava fazendo
mesmo voltou a brincar não encontrou
mais ninguém
e aí a mãe ficou impressionada como se a
filha tivesse deixado aquela obrigação
de ser controladora naquele momento que
a mãe identificou que era é e foi
incrível que foi na hora não foi duas
semanas depois que ela localizou aquilo
então essa ressonância entre pais e
filhos é muito forte ea gente teve que
estudar muito isso porque lá na casinha
amarela os pais participam ativamente da
educação dos filhos
então mesmo com todos os ambientes
preparados
mesmo com todo o espaço para a alta
educação e para as crianças resolver em
situações traumáticas desde a gestação
a gente precisava mudar uma coisa muito
maior que eram os pais porque o
autoritarismo que a gente vinha as
inseguranças dos medos as intervenções
desnecessárias daquele tipo como isso
pega aqui love aquilo que legal vamos
brincar de som intervenções
desnecessárias por um processo de
aprendizagem autônomo
então a gente começou a criar alguns
acordos e um dos nossos primeiros
acordos foi o silêncio que a gente mesmo
não cumprir a gente ficava ali
conversando e como que era estar
conversando atrapalhando as crianças e
desconcentrando como gente ia saber qual
que eram as coisas que elas estavam
precisando para poder criar os ambientes
duráveis então como a gente tinha esse
objetivo nós passamos a nos ajudar né
estávamos todos ali para isso então aos
poucos a gente foi cumprindo esse
objetivo do silêncio não só o silêncio
da fala muito em silêncio interno
e aí quando a gente passou a cumprir
esse objetivo a gente sentiu que nosso
comportamento com as crianças mudou
a gente passou a respeitar mais a
necessidade de cada um
a gente passou a olhar nos olhos da
criança na altura delas e tá ali junto
com ela com elas para resolver aquela
situação para aquele momento com que
fosse necessário para aquela situação
a gente passou a acolher as situações em
que as crianças tinham uma vontade de
chorar um trauma ou qualquer situação de
de choro só colhendo sem extrair
esperando que a criança resolver se
aquilo
e aí todos esses nossos comportamentos
todas essas mudanças foram trazendo pra
gente um convite a uma mudança de padrão
de crenças de quadro familiar de padrão
cultural uma mudança total ea gente
percebeu quando a gente entrava num
estado de neutralidade
aquela ausência de ego ausência de
expectativa a ausência de julgamento
somente estando ali presente e
observando as situações como
experiências 100 certo e errado com
experiências
a gente percebeu que as crianças
demonstravam uma cooperação elas
entravam num estado de cooperação tão
grande tão lindo em tudo que ela se
relacionavam e esse estado de cooperação
a daquele tipo assim que estão brincando
de esconde esconde
aí está escondido o outro está
procurando aí o que estamos procurando
fala que é você ou escondidos ai tô aqui
sozinho cooperativa sempre
então esse essa descoberta das crianças
com as experiências
é uma descoberta na verdade de algo que
ela já tinha uma sabedoria que já tá
nelas que vivendo a experiência
sabedoria só seletiva como nesse caso
por exemplo de uma criança que começa
com despreendimento pela aí pela leitura
é um interesse bem nos prendido mas que
por interpor impulso próprio necessidade
própria vai investigando até o momento
em que aprendi a ler e escrever sozinho
ea gente pode observar aquilo com uma
admirável a uma admiração natural porque
não aquele excesso de euforia que a
criança conseguiu que a criança cumpriu
o objetivo como geralmente os pais ficam
os professores né
e aí esse excesso de expectativa faz com
que a criança fique ansiosa pra
corresponder à necessidade do duto
então uma admiração natural por essa
conquista da criança e é isso que a
gente convida na casinha amarela
então depois desses três anos de
experiência que a gente teve a gente
recebeu muitas mudanças na casa amarela
primeiro quer dizer mal está no
organismo vivo as coisas que acontecem
lá a gente não sabe nem explicar o que
são tantas histórias que eu queria que
eu mando embora todos vocês mas é as
histórias que acontecem sempre são para
despertar as crianças internas de cada
um a nossa criança e se diz perto ali
então na casinha depois que a gente
recebeu um prêmio por uma nova pedagogia
futura
nós começamos a receber muitos
visitantes de todo lugar
e a gente tem uma rotina a gente começa
uma e meia e mais ou menos até 36
crianças ficam livres para fazer o que
quiser
as 36 gente convida para um lanche
depois a gente conviveu com um projeto e
finaliza com a história sempre um
convite e aí uma criança chegou lá
que tal que somada à escola no dia
desses de visitas e quando a gente
convidou para fazer alguma atividade ela
não queria fazer e não fazer nada e o
pai estava um pouco preocupado
então a gente sentou com o pai conversou
com que a rotina do seu filho tal ele
contou a criança natação tinha alta de 2
ela quer a teia para a escola então
o tempo todo ela tinha que cumprir
horários e ali ela podia ser que ela
queria se então a gente incentivou e
deixa vão ver que ele pode fazer vamos
ver quem é o seu filho né
e ao contrário disso depois teve um dia
que chegou uma criança que também
passaram por esse processo de educação
bem direcionado
quando chegou na casa amarela estava
naquele momento 16 13m e crianças acho
que quiser sem nenhum direcionamento ela
olhava sim mas o que tem que fazer aqui
o que nós vamos fazer agora com aquele
monte de coisa pra fazer ela ficou
esperando um direcionamento e esses faz
lindo assim resolveram mudar esse
processo de educação se mudaram a lista
com nossos vizinhos estão com a gente
até hoje trabalhando no novo tipo de
educação das crianças e nos pais também
a gente recebeu muita mudança uma
presença muito maior
um olhar nos olhos das crianças uma
segurança um silêncio observação e não
direcionamento e um cuidado muito maior
com os processos individuais de cada
criança e nas crianças a gente percebeu
coisas maravilhosas elas são super
autônomas criativas seguras elas são
decididas e elas conhecem os seus
limites
então o que o convite que eu tenho pra
fazer hoje aqui pra vocês que o convite
que a casinha tem pra fazer pra gente
quando a gente chega lá pra fazer uma
vivência é esse voltar a ser criança ea
nossa mente ela pode até tentar pensar o
que significa ser criança dentro do que
a gente já conhece mas quando a gente
começa a viver essa criança quando a
gente está disposto a fazer o que tem
que ser feito agora esses títulos
informações deixam de escrever realmente
quem a gente é que a gente passa a viver
o agora sem expectativas em julgamento
sem crença sem paradigmas mas está
pronto para viver o agora
e nessa
nesse momento de viver o agora agente
percebeu que nas nossas imperfeições
a gente está perfeito e que tem que ser
feito
gratidão